make sure that I'm not in your [ __ ] okay
good you're recording you always do this
I've been here once avoid be here what's
in you only always your hair's long I
know right let's look back yeah you're a
tease mafia mafia what's going on reject
nation I'm Greg Alba the Mex illan some
cells Minami Gonzalez is here follow him
on instagram or else we'll never come
back whenever he's visiting from Texas
also as part of the YouTube channel
double toasted which is one of John's
favorite channels but not yours
I just I I can't stand that what's that
guy hey Sammy
what i watch the bumblebee theatrical
trailer but have you seen the
international one or the theatrical I
haven't seen [ __ ] which you can also
watch on Thursdays a double toasted but
that's like my thing I don't watch
things so this will be a genuine
reaction because I've only seen the
first like teaser with bumblebee in the
cobwebs I think is what it was but you
tell you're telling me before I've seen
the transformers cartoon yeah have you
seen the movies like some of them
they'll bleed together it was the one
with like the really racist little tiny
robots and the balls
2 through 4 when I did the reaction in
review for the other trailer everyone's
like you gotta check out the
International one that one's better so
even though I've already seen it the
theatrical one I figured you know what
you haven't seen any of it I am the
internationals watch this one together
right Sammy headphones please headphones
which ones right side I'm committing all
right homie
[Music]
[Music]
the memory core uh he loses his memory
ok well that's true Stanley it's like a
totally different trailer right holy
crap
hey this message find you our war rages
all the boys mentioned over this
Cybertron yeah go on
a star schema Kate what's night and
[Music]
humor okay okay I'm like you know that's
you positive but I like it a lot Oh
first off before we go into anything
right
oftentimes if people ask like to check
out the International I'm like yeah
maybe cuz they're usually very similar
two seconds of extra clip oh that's like
a trailer number three yeah yeah if you
watch the other one it's like a lot of
scenes are expanded upon there's footage
that just flat-out not in the other
trailer okay and even the whole thing
about revealing that he loses his memory
right I don't recall that being in the
other trailer like this trailer takes
its time a lot more and I was actually
kind of blown away by how this is so
different it's not it's more than just a
couple of extra scenes right you get a
much better sense of the scenes and the
tone you can our common enemy isn't
found
the whole planet honestly Sammy this is
what people had in their heads when they
watched the first run of these
live-action ones uh-huh because they
wanted transformers to be so good the
first time around but it looked like
garbage you couldn't tell what was
happening yeah and so they go well here
it's like crisp cut and clear it's beep
it simple stupid
make it look like the things that they
know and so they smooth everything out
they gave me a color and let me go say
yeah they're more vibrant up to this
crimes a truck even though he's on
Cybertron how does that make sense but
even then it looks good and it looks
like they're taking their time and it's
gonna be slower paced yeah well yeah I'm
very much all for because like the other
trailer you still get that vibe but it
definitely moves a lot faster and then
here I'm like oh we're actually getting
like a better taste of how the scenes
might actually play back if you just
pull back a little bit and give a lot
more well I mean what are your opinions
on it so far I feel like I might just
repeat much like I want to see this but
it's that last little bit of comedy that
they threw in where it's like okay you
got a peel of the children I know but
you don't have to go so slapstick II I
get the Transformers inherently are
foolish and kind of dumb okay the 80s
you know the cartoons but when I was
like Beast Wars though the same kind of
like transformer shows they take it's
super serious a lot of times like it's
like a red war and think we have to
fight and this is like Oh bumblebee
you're so silly and wacky and it's like
we don't always need high jinks well
it's a fair criticism and if you don't
like it I totally get it but I'm with
you in this sense of I wonder if it's
gonna feel totally out of place and a
little bit forced
you got one trailer here which is very
like epic it's serious bumblebee just
not remember why he's here
only one way to end this war and they
were friends a little girl but she's in
danger now I don't know I might just be
the fun and games part of like act to
right I guess ya know there's gonna be
character development where they're
gonna be like oh and built a bond and
you have to like bumblebee you have
personality at least I'm fellas in it
has to have personality with bumblebee
so I understand that's what you're doing
to develop that but as you saw with some
of those middle two three four
transformers they got too silly we got
too crazy they got too out of hand it
was and it just worked to the detriment
of it's true I agree well here I said in
the last reaction that I don't know who
the other Decepticons are and then I
want to be educating which is how the
double toast of families does not treat
Sammy when he wants to be go watch my
show the red one is a female Decepticon
called shatter that's my Angela Bassett
Jesus bring it in and then the blue one
is dropkick and the red jet one is
Blitzwing everyone like that was
Starscream right yeah except but it
wasn't actually Starscream right I mean
if they're rebooting this whole
franchise you can't you know burst your
love that early that's true I mean they
did in the first started I started
watching the transformers cartoon I
bought the first season okay
because that dedicated to it there was
that robot dog whose name I can't write
I was like a bunch of them in the movie
there's like a couple dog yeah but I'm
imagining because they're on Cybertron
here that it might be that same dog for
a write one that was in the show from
the first three episodes which for my
nostalgia factor on this dog four days
ago I remember fondly that gets me
excited but we were we were looking at
the clips from the old trailer shouldn't
find out that dog whoa yeah but they do
have the cassette player once at
Soundwave
yeah that's like the dumbest transformer
but simultaneously the best trans
he's a cassette tape and then he's like
we even he's a robot and then he goes
inside of another robot like that's what
I liked about the animated movie was
that you had all of them together to
have you
big-ass war yeah and then you guys see
some of them die and stuff like if this
builds to that mm-hmm
I can't wait for like the second or
third one of this series I guess um one
thing with the marketing that I'm
actually kind of questionable about the
other trailer when I look back on it I
was thinking did we really need to see
Optimus Prime
do we need to reveal that but here it
actually looks like he's a part of the
story as opposed to just hey we need
thrown out to miss Prime guys because it
looks like Optimus sent him there and
you know he forgot his mission he's got
a Bourne Identity case going on did you
really think they were gonna have a
Transformers movie without Optimus Prime
no but at the same time I thought was
thinking it might have been cooler to
just let it still be revealed when
you're watching it Hollywood doesn't
know how to be cool they know how to be
money give your money good money and
they go oh we need money I mean I have
to be when it comes to things like this
it's like we need money let's make sure
the first trailer the teaser that was
like because you've like bumblebee right
but how are we gonna make money
throw-in Optimus Prime who's the voice
actor Optimus Prime super famous Peter :
thank you job thanks John Peter Colin is
in it with his badass voice and so that
triggers all that nostalgia it gets the
gears going and it's gonna set this one
off right without the explosions without
the Shia LaBeouf without Megan Fox ass
and some people might like that but too
much this is ready to be a money-making
machine again for that well the thing is
with this international trailer it
relieves that like annoyance of showing
that to me because he seems like an
essential part of the plot right as
opposed to throwing a cameo okay I kind
of want to see that that's kind of
something I've always wanted to see it
was like a proper Mack truck old style
off of his prime busting through all
those army guys I can't wait for
probably get it cool lead in there and I
think to what what this trailer also
gave me was the villain seem much better
than any of the many Megatron
appearances we've got in the truck
yeah the villains here seem personal
like they really hate bumblebee and I
like that idea of like we need him we're
also gonna destroy her that's a good way
to hook in the military to working for
the Decepticons right to save the planet
it's like this seems like John Cena he's
a bad guy but it's a really a bad guy
that's never really a bad guy not even
wrestling what else like the old
Megatron look like this jar of pens this
is great it was like the great classic
Transformers B's yeah this is what I
mean
nerds sometimes including myself don't
know what they want and so it's like
should they make an exact replica of the
80s cartoon and then the first run
they're like no we got to make a more
dynamic we got to make it more like that
but then this time around it's like okay
we're gonna make it just like the same
thing with Power Rangers it's like I'm
like a Power Rangers kid that was 90s
right
yeah and then they made it a gritty
reboot Goldar was like molten gold yeah
and the mech was like all slender neat
but it's like no give me the blocky one
exactly and so the next one has the
blocky one that's gonna be me going yes
the same is what I know
beyond that though I think that even if
I hadn't seen the cartoons to have a any
frame of reference at all to see with
like oh this color palette and the way
the transformer is looking a lot of
people are talking about like the g1
Optimus and all that even if I hadn't
seen any of those imagery I would be
more drawn to this imagery beyond the
Michael Bay burr yeah it's simple it's
just it's colorful easier to see and
they're smaller it's like it's not too
much the trailers in the marketing
aren't treating it's solely as this is
for the fans and this is only for the
nostalgia factor it's done in a way
where I feel like it can be appealing
for people who haven't been drawn to the
Transformers movies so I'm all on board
for this man it's the first Transformers
movie I'm genuinely excited for mm-hmm
I just like look I kind of mentioned
they're smaller I like that like you're
not like Gundams they're not like these
big monster like bumblebees like a car
that can stand out that's cool exactly
and so I'm excited for it cautiously
optimistic but it's it's gonna be that
humor it'll live and die by the humor
that they decided to put in but the
studio said got to make it funny
got to make it further children will
Sammy Marvel's funny all the reason
whether everything should be funny why
those movies are good because they're
funnies are funny Oh star-lord he's a
rascal
Oh Iron Man he's narcissistic but he's
funny quips so much Bonnie is in funny
make it funny everything's funny
predator predators funny
everyone's funny as long as you're funny
be funny
alright guys thanks for watching you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification Bell check us on
patreon got TV show reactions Q&A is a
whole bunch of goodies more importantly
follow sammy gonzales over on instagram
at the underscore mechs alliance i
follow him he sends me dick pics and you
should also check him out on double
toasted they're fantastic youtube
channel he's the main face of the
channel call me it's all by myself
there's some guy Corey and Martin are
supporting players on there but it's
Sammy a throwing bone no yeah every once
in a while they might get to cover
something small but Sammy he's the big
dog over there he's the big player go
check him out